[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en cet instant j'hésite à franchir le
pas le premier pas vers vous au visage
voilé
car le premier pas franchi je sais que
je ne m'arrêterais plus que j'irai
vaille que vaille jusqu'au bout de ma
tâche
[Musique]
je voudrais que tout ce que j'ai à dire
ce soir ici une année à de confidences
il m'en coûterait trop de vous laisser
le souvenir d'un homme qui aurait
prétendu comme tant d'autres imposer sa
manière de voir quand vous propose plus
maintenant des idées on cherche par tous
les moyens à vous les imposer à
s'emparer de votre pensée je voudrais
qu'on n'a pas respecté le mieux la
liberté de votre pensée ainsi s'exprimer
en effet georges bernanos en 1945 nous a
quittés en 1948 il est connu surtout
pour les grands romans qui les grands
romans qu'il a écrit mais on ignore plus
une part de son oeuvre qu'il a appelée
les écrivent combats qui ont été mal
compris lors de son vivant mais qui
aujourd'hui je crois prennent une totale
résonance il poursuivait en effet un c
[Musique]
holmes l'europe méfiez-vous méfiance
hommes d'europe
si vous n'y prenez garde ce que les
dictateurs ont voulu faire en quelques
années sera fait en 50 ou 100 mais le
résultat sera le même
l'état aura tous conquis tout séduit
tout absorbé vous n'aurez échapper aux
demi-dieux totalitaire que pour retomber
tout doucement dans la glu de la
dictature anonyme
l'état aura décidément pris votre
bien-être à sa charge et la mort seul
vous délivrera de son énorme sollicitude
écoutez bien en europe on essaie de nous
faire croire qu'il n'ya aucun moyen
d'échapper à cette monstrueuse
croissance
quelle est la nature des choses et bien
moi je vous dis qu'elle n'est pas dans
la nature de l'homme que l'homme s'il
veut aura le dernier mot sur les choses
à le comprendre et vous enfin pomme
d'europe les tailles d'une assurance
contre les risques
si vous prétendez vous faire garantir
par lui contre les risques qu'on santé
et changer le titre de citoyen comptant
celui d'assister le bonheur est un
risque mais le monde veut plus courir ce
risque il ne souhaite la sécurité il
n'avance pas à payer cette sécurité à
n'importe quel prix il est dupe de tout
ce que lui promettent ils acceptent
aveuglément n'importe quel programme qui
prétend lui assurer le bonheur et le
malheur forme également les grands
peuples mais la sécurité fait les
esclaves
[Musique]
hélas le monde risque de perdre la
liberté de la perdre irréparablement
faute d'avoir gardé l'habitude de s'en
servir
je voudrais avoir un moment le contrôle
de tous les postes de radio de la
planète pour dire aux hommes
attention prenez garde la liberté et là
sur le bord de la route
mais vous passez devant elle sans
tourner la tête oui voilà l'appel que je
voudrais lancer à travers l'espace mais
je crains que la liberté ne soit déjà
pour beaucoup plus qu'un mot tels que
ceux de vie de mort de morale tel est le
résultat de la propagande incessante
fait depuis tant d'années par tous ceux
qui dans le monde se trouvent intéressé
à la formation d'une humanité docile
de plus en plus docile à mesure que
l'organisation économique exige une
réglementation plus minutieuse
[Musique]
ce qu'il met pour vente
dieu veuille que je vous fasse partager
mon époux vente ce n'est pas que le
monde moderne détruisent tout c'est
qu'il ne s'enrichissent nullement de ce
qu'il détruit en détruisant il se
consomme cette civilisation est une
civilisation de consommation qui durera
aussi longtemps qu'il y aura quelque
chose à consommer sont l'unique loi
paraît être la production elle-même la
production à outrance la production sans
mesure
mais cette production monstrueuse ce
gigantisme de la pré production est
précisément le signe du désordre auquel
elle ne peut manquer de succomber
en détruisant elle se consomme en
produisant elle se détruit la
civilisation mécanique et
concentrationnaire produit des
marchandises et dévore les hommes on ne
serait fixé de limite à la production
des marchandises la civilisation
mécanique ne s'arrêtera de produire des
marchandises que dans le moment qui leur
a dévoré les hommes elle les aura
dévorer ont légué en masse ces normes
epa montceau mais elle doit également
dévorer un parent elle les aura bon d un
parent de leur moelle de leur âme
la substance spirituelle qui les
faisaient hommes oui je vois se
construire un monde où ce n'est pas
assez d'irena ce que l'homme ni pour
vivre il pourra vivre mais à la
condition de moins en moins homme
[Musique]
l'humanité malades beaucoup plus malade
qu'on le croit et c'est ce qu'il faut
d'abord reconnaître afin de la prendre
en pitié
l'humanité est menacée de périr et les
docteurs semble s'intéresser à son
agonie qu pour en tirer des arguments
favorables à leur thèse il montre le
prescrivent il condamne il ferait
beaucoup mieux des mais l'homme moderne
n'est pas un élève parent et ceux qui
jouent avec les machines au lieu d'
apprendre ses leçons
les machines distrait à prendre ce mot
devenu banal non dans son acception
ordinaire mais dans son sens exact elle
l'a achetée à lui-même et à ses
angoisses
il est sans doute permis de se demander
comment une machine à laver la vaisselle
par exemple est capable d'arracher
l'homme ses angoisses
il semblait même que toutes ces
mécanismes qui est ingénieuse n'ont
d'autre but que de faire gagner du temps
que loin d'arracher l'homme à ses
angoisses
elle lui laisse plus de temps pour en
remâche et l'amertume
cela n'est malheureusement vrai qu'en
apparence
l'homme moderne profite rarement de ses
loisirs la besogneuse fait il se
contente de changer de machine il va
précipitamment de machines en machines
ainsi qu'un joueur de jazz band
il ne s'agit d'ailleurs ici que des
machines utilitaire celle qu'il a le
plus aimés pour lesquelles ils ne
cessent d'épuiser toutes les ressources
de son génie inventif sont précisément
celles qui s'ajuste correspondent pour
ainsi dire exactement au réflexe naturel
de défense dans l'angoissé
le mouvement qui grise la lumière qui
réconfortent les voix qui rassure
[Musique]
où
dans le monde moderne et face à toutes
les emprises de l'économie qu'est ce qui
peut bien rester de l'homme l'homme mais
plus face à l'économie
son autonomie est en train de
disparaître il est englobé corps et âme
dans l'économie c'est l'apparition
réelle d'une nouvelle espèce d'homme
l'homme économique
ah oui je sais bien ce modèle économique
crée tout de suite à un malentendu on
pense malgré soi un brave type économe
qui met ses sous dans un bas de laine
mais l'homme dont je parlais pas
précisément économe il est capable de
dissiper des richesses immenses un
nombre incalculable de vies humaines
oui la tyrannie n'est pas derrière nous
elle est devant nous et nous voulu faire
face maintenant ou jamais
[Musique]
assez s'exprimait donc se lance sur d'
alerte avant la lettre
jorge banos entre 1945 et 1948 l'année
où il est mort mais pour autant ils nous
invitaient pas à la résignation
même au désespoir bernanos n'était pas
un pessimiste pour lui l'optimiste et le
pessimiste
ce sont deux imbéciles l'un est un
imbécile heureux l'autre un imbécile
malheureux non dans la noce face à
toutes les crises auxquelles l'humanité
et nous mêmes et chacun de nous devons
faire face aujourd'hui et coûte que
coûte comme dirait dans l'anus surmonter
face à tout cela balanos nous habite
je sais que le mot on peut paraître un
peu ridicule mais prend toute sa force
aujourd'hui à une invincible espérances
car il sait lui qui a traversé la
première guerre mondiale
la deuxième guerre mondiale la guerre
d'espagne les totalitarismes tout ce
20ème siècle ensanglantée il sait qu'au
bout de chaque nuit se lève une nouvelle
aurore aussi conclut-il ainsi
[Musique]
le monde ne sera sauvé que par les âmes
les bruns
[Musique]
on me dit que l'homme n'est pas libre
mais qu'ils me prouvent laisser nos
monuments le contraire je répondrai à
montaut puisque tout ceci doit se
résoudre en fin de compte par un pari eh
bien je parie pour l'homme le monde ne
sera sauvé que par les hommes libres
on vous dit la liberté ne peut pas
mourir elle peut mourir dans le coeur
des hommes
le sort de la liberté est liée au sort
de l'homme libre la liberté l homme
libre le monde sera sauvée que par les
hommes libres
notre civilisation s'est fondé sur une
certaine définition de l'homme commune à
tous nos penseurs croyants ou non
croyants celle de l'homme libre
c'est cette liberté de l'homme qui donne
à la personne humaine son caractère
sacré
le monde ne sera sauvé que par les
hommes libres
[Musique]
oui il ne s'agit pas de savoir si cette
liberté en les hommes heureux ou même
mot il me suffit qu'elles rendent
l'homme plus sommes plus digne de sa
redoutable vocation d'homme
le monde ne sera sauvé que par les âmes
libre il faut faire un monde
pour les âmes les bras
[Musique]
hu
merci
[Applaudissements]